I can't do anything I don't have a knife
or anything nice you never like walk
into a room and see something go that
would look cool in my place I can't see
I can't I can't make food look nice I
can cook well I'm a good cook but I
can't quite uh I'd said that I know what
that term is
yeah yeah I just learned that because my
wife watches a lot of Food Network they
go yeah the food was good but you didn't
played it well and I'm like I don't care
how it looks
put it out yeah I just been out I mean
walk around all day in an inside-out
t-shirt would you have your own show you
could do that yes right well see but see
but now you're you're you're a
trendsetter so people go Oh Jim Jeffries
is wearing his shirt yeah oh yeah
all right what's wrong weakly I can't
quite dress myself either I've just
black t-shirts converse and black jeans
is all I can really do yeah yeah you
know and then like I get dressed at work
someone dresses me is that yeah I can't
you have to think as far as underwear
pants and t-shirt right you at least
have to just get to the place clothes
yeah I have to get the base Wow even
then they give me socks and everything
and like it's like I'm doing Jimmy
Kimmel tomorrow and there's I just
walked in there's an outfit hanging on
the rack said you're Kimmel outfit man
you're living you're a [ __ ] yeah yeah
you're living the life of a five year
old Jim someone dresses you someone
feeds if you watch my show I think
people think very little of me because
all the joy oh oh my right is right all
the jokes are like this and you know so
obviously I didn't watch that and you
because I was drunk
[Laughter]
like like bah bah bah bah cuz i can't
bathe myself you know what that's a real
look in the mirror is once you get
people to write for you cuz I go oh this
is what people assume Jim is like this
is what his world is like I'm taking a
bit of cockeyed the way they describe me
like I'm [ __ ] twitching the whole car
with I
I want the I want the listeners to know
this as you're saying that you are
twitching
I always tweet well that's from the
cocaine just a bit tweaking what how
would you guys start writing on what
they're upstairs writing now directly
above us right now which is also weird
because I got a pinball machine in my
office yeah yeah and so sometimes I like
got into the writers room and then I'm
like hey look guys look I can't be up
here for a while I got a lot of stuff
that I got to do other things for the
show and then all they hear is ding ding
ding I do the George Costanza walk
around the office like ah busy yeah yeah
followed the whole talk so they go oh
gee Jim's flat out yeah ding ding ding
ding ding well that's when you say
that's your emotional support pinball
machine that I emotionally support use
for like 5 hours out of my 8 hours right
I think you do need things like that
though right to like it as a break yeah
I find it very calming yeah oh yeah very
calming right you think ever be like
like you know the way Gabriel Iglesias
has like a [ __ ] ton of VW bugs you think
you'll ever just get a it's like ah
here's this be warehouse filled with B
dubs and then just [ __ ] stuff plush
toys of me paint
yeah thanks that tanked yeah they do a
celebrity paint I thought that was a new
show yeah I think I rented that uh
tanked is the celebrity aquariums
separate aquariums yeah I mean and then
these two Jersey guys that live in Vegas
oh yeah Jersey with East Coast guys and
they're always like we got to get this
tape we got to get this fish take two
fluffy right away now we can't let him
dig a dent and there's always like a
problem yes that's always laugh but is
it really it's not gonna fit in is
always like this way was it episode like
we gotta make a pinball machine into a
fish tank and if we don't do it
Fluffy's not gonna be happy
we gotta get this done because fluffy
puppies like the nicest fluffy we better
get this done tonight they converted a
v-dub into a fish tank and then there
was like at somebody a inspected
regularly my manager and agent some
something they said our tank isn't quiet
if you want a fish tank anywhere baby
I've never had an interested fish in my
child yeah but now someone gives you the
option look around the office like a
weird like I'd like a nice rectangular
one now just sits in the corner with ya
simple fish simple goldfish you know you
need like a barracuda Nemo yeah it has
to be a glass microphone filled with a
shot yeah yeah they did one of those for
Tracy Morgan right I can only imagine
what was in his fish tank these things I
call it fluffy yeah because he had he's
bdub converted into a fish tank yeah
yeah it was good yeah I was brilliant
fish thing I go I go well you know it's
the upkeep it it's hard you have to feed
them and then slam it what about in my
what about the hiatus the show that we
have to bring someone in to take care of
the fish all right stop and I go okay so
how do you do it with you bdub fish yeah
guys most of the fish is dead now filled
with water well this is my very
expensive fish coffin it's a good water
in there anymore hold like I've seen in
movies where they'll have like you know
funerals for fish and stuff but is that
insane to like have like and what like
where do you draw the line for animal
burials you know I'm saying there's not
we just kind of we had a lot of cats and
dogs going on I think what Dad just
buried him in the yard
I don't remember ceremony yeah yeah I
remember like in TV they always sit
around
right what digest I got home from school
the cat was in the backyard that's your
version of the the cat had to go to a
farm it's like Oh where's the where's
the cat in the backyard like a like a
cross that's presumptuous thing though
like as I've seen people put crosses
down for the religious cat yeah it's
like oh I don't know you never know the
cat could be Buddhist yeah yeah cuz what
because isn't Buddhist like you get
reincarnated unless you accept Jesus
into your heart you can't get into hit
it's like we're the only animal that has
to rock that out Yeah right
was raping each other they're all right
yeah yeah yeah they're doing a lot of
that and then everyone goes like ah but
there's a dog in heaven and there's a
and and there's a fish heaven and
there's a hamster heavens like are they
all separated yeah yeah yeah why don't
we get to yeah I'd like to be able to
see my dog again is there a show you
were mentioning about them asking about
tank but is there a show like a chopped
or something like that that you are
Iying or they have asked you to do that
you have any other skills great on like
I wonder if there's any footage of this
around because I just I I haven't got it
but yeah what happened was they had a
thing in England that was Premier League
teams and it was like itis size on these
sort of like a bigger than a father
slash football thing and so half the
team with ex-professional Premier League
players
that soccer Adam right yeah English
Premier League okay English Premier
League plays and the other half were
fans of the team who were celebrities
yeah no okay Manchester United and stuff
like had like the good people yeah
[ __ ] James Bond yeah yeah he was
[ __ ] right they had big celebrities
playing man you know I'm living for
Chelsea have been I support for okay
Fulham were pretty hard stock to find
some celebrities a Hugh Grant supports
full of business he was out of town okay
right I didn't want to do it
so it was you and like a nice extra on
The Love Boat it was me and this is
years ago I wasn't I was I was a club
coming
this isn't Jim Jefferies HBO special
acts I could have showed two out of
tickets maybe in a small theater like
this okay nothing ten years ago and so
it was it was me and I wasn't let me
finish then right I was I was drinking
pretty heavily mm-hmm at that stage I
was bit puffier and I thought oh god I
got to go play professional sport on TV
couldn't kick the soccer ball since I
was about ten uh-huh and they go can you
play soccer because I gotta be playing
with professional [ __ ] yeah yeah David
Seaman the English England goalkeeper
for [ __ ] a decade we in goals yeah
this right this is big deal right a
televised life ah anyway so I got the
Jersey I got the full outfit I got the
full kit before she guards I bought a
new pair of boots like oh I got your
orange slices all ready to go guy who
came fifth on Britain's Got Talent
and then another guy who he wasn't
famous yet but he's very famous now a
good example
it's a rapper he's a rapper okay sort of
a hip puppy very white guy okay for very
popular nice like if you watch any of
examples songs like that haven't got a
20 million hits but he wasn't famous
then either right so this so we rock out
there now we play the game and these
things about yourself you don't realize
until you watch yourself back on tape
mm-hmm right
I had no idea that I have an awkward run
the real eyes yeah because when you're
running and you feel comfortable yeah it
you feel like it's natural to you all
right next to the you yeah nobody should
think about being judged on yeah yeah
yes you're just running yeah yeah he's
right
I have horrendous no I have like I have
like a sort of like a skip to it
oh you run like a dwarf
so we right I have a definite like
Quasimodo sort of thing yeah and I have
one risk that sort of kicks off to the
side
oh no you can I have it one that goes
forward
yeah like looking for food yeah I had no
idea have you always had that I liked so
much education
finally finally found this out in my in
my mid to late 20s when I watch this so
I got home watch the game I didn't do
anything good I didn't I was so bad
athletically that every time and these
were like the premier league
commentators the official coda is every
time the ball came me me they started
laughing
[Laughter]
Jeffries Jeffries Jeffries is chasing
after the boat quite the rod on him
quite the run on him that's such a
that's such a passive-aggressive British
way to insult someone I'm super
competitive so I was like I had these
sporting dreams that maybe yeah one good
thing yeah yeah I didn't do any do you
have any ethics skill have you got
another better yeah have you gotten to
throw out a first pitch yet right
because you have never seen my first
pitch it is no ah [ __ ] me okay this is
also before I was famous I was doing the
Chicago Comedy Festival
yeah and so for the week of the Chicago
Comedy Festival they let at the club's
games three comedians for the three
games that were on it and when comedians
got the three pitches
awesome and louis c.k got they were
playing did the day before and then I
did one day and I can't really who did
the last my Bonnie Hunt yeah
but they give me now they give me a Cubs
Jersey this is online you could watch
this this is bad right and what happens
is I walk out now I have really bad call
that day with no excuses but I'd had a
cold all that week and I add I did plan
that I'd have a few practice goes sure
you want to yeah didn't have one
so nerves are high yeah also
so this might sound a bit weird to you
also when I was walking out there I lady
handed me the ball as I was walking out
there my brain went and spoke to spoke
to myself and with the third person yeah
Jim you've never held a baseball before
and you're a baseball fan these like 9
years ago as I've been in America for
about a hot minute there's me like here
what's this and I was like I feel sort
of the same way there's a cricket ball
case right now right
and I never done a I'd never practiced
one picture anything and so I thought
how hard could it be right and then I
was up on the mound I thought these and
then I would say I got it
six feet off to the left all right but
you made it the whole way in hit the
dirt it made a distance he's been off to
the lip I made the distance but yeah but
it was no good
yeah but there the thing is right I
actually like I like the Cubs but I
never want them to win anything I was
like they were like I love you because
there was a mistake if the team that
never won yeah the real reason I don't
want them to ever win is because of the
video clip that's on YouTube is just off
someone's phone or these two [ __ ]
Chicago [ __ ] this [ __ ] sitting there
going hey go back to Australia [ __ ] it
that's right boys right not even worth
the handshake
we'll have a seat
yeah yeah yeah they they're like they're
relentless I gotta go wait so you tried
commentating while taping you doing the
first but I got a little booty a common
tight they film it
they are commentating it I get a little
boo as I'm walking off I give a little
wave and then it calves like it every
out because it's Wrigley Field every
other stadium has boxes and [ __ ] then I
take you up through the day
right they just gave me a seat in like
the fifth row right now you're sitting
all around people walk back into this
dynein as people booed me and then
people cheered me as I came to sit down
it really makes you feel warm and
welcome yeah throughout the game we're
saying horrible things to me I was if
it's three hours okay
there is heckling you the whole time
right in your twenties yeah now I've
always liked just so those people don't
have good days right
I want the Cubs to lose just so those
people these people are miss man this
makes me real nervous I just found out
that I'm throwing out the first pitch at
an Angels game and I'm a fan of the
Angels so I don't want something like
that to happen to me all the Angels fans
are very nice people here I get that
you'll get just a blond Republican mom
you just described my mother perfect we
decide what he should do and yeah
whether it's the worm or a cartwheel
into the throw yeah yeah all right so
you'll be fine but I mean he's gotta do
something pre he can't just throw it
right yeah because they're comedian you
gotta do something I don't know if
they're good at sports or bad sports or
whatever but jock Peterson the Dodgers
plays he's brother his champ Peterson
and champ has Down syndrome
okay he's always at the games and they
you know you they sort of let him be a
batboy or this or that he always sort of
in the celebrations as laughing you know
anyway champ Peterson came out and threw
the first pitch yeah [ __ ] but really
by guy's voice frozen rope well yeah but
do you know any warmer down syndrome who
isn't freakishly strong yeah
which is accurate yeah but that's yeah
iiiii was watching our way all these kid
guy Harley wrong and then I felt like
maybe I'm disabled list yeah I just
assumed that dancer Joe people are good
at throwing yeah why why why wouldn't
they be no right the kid in my high
school why crime is I wouldn't ask you
Tyler who had Down syndrome in our
school he was like a seventh year senior
and he beat up a teacher once he was
that strong all right that that that'll
be a interesting thing if there ever
gets to the point where there's a Down
syndrome MMA fighter and they walk to
the front of the slide and they go we're
going on what's our play going on each
slide like that is there Wow
then I like there was like a a Mexican
guy with his kid mm-hm
[Laughter]
buffer it out it's so even at the water
park amongst all the chaos there isn't
etiquette like between you know ya race
it's just that's just a situation where
if they start like if you don't see the
lead-up if you just see you thought like
is it like maybe I should say something
because that's the right thing to do it
and it's not about race it's just about
the X Y a teachable moment like hey
those girls cut the line and not like
hey these little black girls yeah you
know yeah whose parents are not even
here like my son his brain mm-hmm
couldn't compute why they this is a this
is something you got to learn about yeah
those are one of those teachable moment
do you break something like that down to
them afterwards like when do you see a
moment to where you go alright there
might be some sort of like you know
parent lesson here to only if you asked
about it yeah told a couple of young
teenagers often you know you're old ya
doing get off my lawn yeah in London top
of the buses when they're playing their
music through their phone yeah yeah sure
but I think like you said especially now
just probably not a good idea
there's it's weird that well I just
think as a person
famous was a person who has a TV show
can you hook this a little bit more as
president of TV Asia
I think that my my I'm not allowed to
tell people to [ __ ] off in public
anymore
yeah right I've lost me [ __ ] you yeah
you can't just throw in a strong random
[ __ ] you every now and then yeah I can't
my god just being like a story guy
you're a [ __ ] yeah now you can save
people now like you're almost like you
can get more press for that and you're
almost like you can help someone out
yeah then you'll get more credit than
you should
yes but then you can't tell someone okay
I don't do it for the glory sometimes
I've had a few babies I will be known to
do an outrageously big tip alright I'll
do that ready I'll do the the the ten
dollar meal $1,000 tip oh geez and I do
that about four or five times a year it
makes you know who I do it - who's that
- it - the Uglies tip from me ya know
cuz I did it once - a good-looking
person and they just sort of went that's
how life works
oh yeah the Uglies give you a hagen star
is ugly hug better than a good-looking
hug because you know that that's genuine
they literally say these anything like
for me in mind you don't know how much
this is just yeah I get that one whereas
if you do it to a hot person it's just
like they're like I don't even work here
this is part of my community service
like I got people playing for [ __ ] ready
you know they used to it yeah hot people
get privileges oh I'm sorry I did it to
a party and nobody was like thanks that
was the level of thanks oh my god is the
crying I paid for this moment
show me emotion let me feel good yeah
I'll even tell you a bit more I normally
do it what I'm gonna dice
a lot of different liars going on on one
audience I'm trying to make an ugly
happy when yeah we're the ugly cries
then event I've done a lot Amy Schumer
keep someone like seven on the box and
bikes the news I never had the big
[ __ ] see it's like you want to give
the tip and then afterwards go hey you
tweet about they want to tell you
friends what a great guy you at harvey
levin with this yes let him know what's
up now is that is that one of the perks
of being you is you get is you will send
you stuff huh from where give them a
plug what is this let me pay from okay
okay so your transaction yeah mm-hmm
what are we feel about Chris Hardwick
and what happened there okay I don't I
don't feel like I know I know
secondhand facts about I haven't done my
own research I know that she cheated on
him he went out of his way to make calls
to people to say don't work with her
yeah so that's all I don't think I had I
don't I don't know enough what are these
text messages are where she tried to get
him back I just know that if and there
are some of my ex-girlfriends where if
they wrote an expose about me
it wouldn't be favorable yeah yeah yeah
and there there's also a thing nowadays
that I'm kind of curious about where
certain people like if you get busted
for something even if you do time or
maybe you get fired from one job like
they're there some people just think oh
you should be just banned from show
business for life like you like you
can't work anymore because you were an
[ __ ] to somebody and why is our
business the woman that we get
five for him yeah it's not like it's not
like someone goes well there's this guy
from he's [ __ ] ex-girlfriend says
he's a piece of [ __ ]
mm-hmm yeah that's plumbing forever yeah
you can you kind of expect that you kind
of expect the plumber to have an X
somewhere that's like kind of mad at him
yeah do that yeah it is sort of an
interesting woman yeah marinara was able
to do what he was doing for quite some
time until until that a real boy here we
go
just one thing I'm like they were
expensive dildos one thing I'm gonna
defend them at okay the the lock under
the desk yeah okay that is a good right
it's like so you see what his was
probably things right there I be distant
be doors there yeah I let myself in so
no one comes yes someone knocks on the
door I have to get up look think I'm
gonna come in and then when they leave
and then when they leave I have to walk
over and lock it again yeah that's a lot
I can I want to lock on them I wanna
look more did you now can you write yeah
can you order it with a specific sign
that says lock under desk not for
parenthesis not for raping I think if
you're making any sort of listens all
right which brings us to the next thing
okay we believe mm-hmm this office you
were sitting in right now
all right it was Bill Cosby's office
during The Cosby Show
really this very office it's very rooms
have you found any quaaludes hidden in
the Cosby's I was filmed in a studio
that we filming holy [ __ ] this was the
building this is obviously the room that
you would always give to the head person
I said I might be the head writers of
his design but our belief is that this
was Cosby's office was there a couch in
the room no
that's good how much can you separately
before that it was Nikki Glaser's office
and there was a couch in the room no I
don't want to say anything about Nikki
Glaser but we know she's got many
similarities because both comedians does
that is that it doesn't mean Fat Albert
does that is that cool when you hear
that or is it like tainted now like when
you first started I'm not sure I think
it's a quickie fun story hell yeah I
think it's one of these things that Lucy
was filmed on this law to write you know
she was Lucy was over in the @midnight
I'm studio yeah we had our was Cosby
Shaw in The Fresh Prince nice okay nice
to know that you're in that thread I did
one season of MADtv here now yeah it's a
it's a pretty cushy all auditor yeah
it's pretty cool there's a lot of
history for a while that like the
RuPaul's Drag Race was being filmed
which is my favorite TV show I need to
watch there's you are maybe the third
comedian I've talked to in the last two
weeks that swears by that show can you
enlighten us maybe enlighten you because
I have a wife so I know a lot about room
yeah you would watch it without it my ex
was a very very girly girl very
effeminate and she just loved RuPaul's
Drag Race right she she had a lot of gay
friends yeah yeah like she liked drag
queens before that and and so she
watched it and then it's the only thing
and I used to be like oh god I gotta
watch RuPaul's Drag Race right but then
I found after we separated I didn't
[Laughter]
report if you got yourself a drag name
oh my own drag name oh boy I think
there's already enough wrong with me I
don't know like a drag name there
like a combination thing like you know
it's not like a gaming right just give
yourself something you think your drag
queen there's no like stripper thing
like your street pleasures they saw
those to be a little pun II like there
was one called penny tration Sharon
Needles okay I love that Sharon Needles
is one of them I remember their I
remember there was a guy named Ben but
he always would play Beyonce so he was
Ben Yonsei I said that matter of fact I
love that yeah you did but my one his
you know its tail order yeah my one is
STD well they always say name yourself
aad I would probably I mean I'm trying
to think of a stupid dwarf pun like like
short D like de like shorty but I don't
I don't think that's I don't think
that's flaming baby mine will because I
was a fat kid yeah I always made jokes
about having boobs as a fact it's made
mine could be kid titty kid titty are
you allergic to great dragon I like kids
yeah I don't know how much I can say
about this but I am connected to a
project okay on TV as a producer I'm
connected you know what it's not the kid
Teddy story I am I'm loosely connected
at the moment and the to a show that's
being pitched with a entire dwarf cast
well why am I just here yeah well now is
this like because I did a I was asked to
do a show one time that was gonna be a
bachelor knockoff oh my god it aired
it's called the littlest groom and it
was a dwarf called the little room and
there was a Worf guy who was going out
with a bunch of dwarf chicks bachelor
style and then the twist was Jim
is that halfway to the show they brought
in tall women so now so now the dwarf
guy was like yeah you you girls are good
but I like these tall women over here
there's a new shake of the proposal
where they don't even they just be on
each other for an hour and propose
sounds like Hollywood yeah it's the
story of one episode the women was
smoking yeah
oh my god give it a go for you try it
out would you ever have you been asked
to do like Dancing with the Stars
no I once asked to do one in Britain
right before I moved here which was
celebrity boot camp that to lose weight
it was like literally go to boot camp
it's gonna be a general like in the army
okay where there was gonna be a Jane it
was gonna be like me and like X boy band
members in Britain and some fun oh yeah
no no guys to payments for that there's
gonna be just the like a whole lot of
reality TV and and it was like I had
nothing going on so I signed onto it and
then like someone where I didn't want to
come to an HBO special in America when
I'm like [ __ ] you think wow because I
was like I was doing that um probably
lose a bit of white but it's literally
like I was gonna have someone just
calling me you maggot you I could get
down and give me 20
I was good at that [ __ ] all day past you
running through swamps with a log over
me and I was like how many specials were
better than that
yes sir I was guy I was going to do that
one I believe there's been inquiries for
me to do I'm a celebrity get me out of
here yeah in some some of the other
other countries
okay I don't want to do that either yeah
let's be good you gotta eat [ __ ] bugs
and [ __ ]
eyeballs and Kalpana psa's and [ __ ] I
won't do that
yeah now you did mention special so I
want make sure we plug your special your
special yeah Friday 13th coming in it's
all bit called this is me now and it's
gonna be on Netflix or is it this is me
now which we this is this is me now is
the punchline to a big story that's in
the roots
it's not like and I said people are
already getting into me like oh look too
before before he was a libertine [ __ ]
[ __ ] oh I came back was just hook is it
dragon yeah and this special only has
like I'm gonna say four minutes on shop
in the whole world it's four minutes
cool and that's it was that on purpose
yeah last special freedom that was sort
of like oh yeah I only had five minutes
of jump nein no rest it was all about
the Constitution yeah yeah and all the
freedoms and what type of stuff wasn't
about trying and that was before Trump
was voted even when I what I really
believed he didn't have a chance in hell
I was like well this is this the funny
thing you just do five minutes cuz this
guy's not gonna win I'll tell you what
happened with that cuz that that clip
went viral I Netflix actually said to me
they go we're not sure like if we need
to make cutlets cut this Trump routine
mhm because by the time the special
comes out a few months later he'll just
be forgotten about you know I mean yeah
right now I won't even be talking about
him and then the joke will date really
Bailey really quickly know I once asked
to do one in Britain right before I
moved here which was celebrity boot camp
that to lose weight it was like
literally go to boot camp it's gonna be
a general like in the army okay where
there was gonna be a Jane it was gonna
be like me and like X boy band members
in Britain and some fun oh yeah no guy
he's too famous for that there's gonna
be just the like a whole lot of reality
TV and and it was like I had nothing
going on so I signed onto it and then
like someone went hey do you want to
come to an HBO special in America or
when I'm like [ __ ] you okay think why
because I was like and I was doing that
I probably lose a bit of weight
but it's literally like I was gonna have
someone who's calling me you maggot get
down and give me 20
get that [ __ ] all day past you yeah
running through swamps the log over me
how many specials were although better
than that yes sir I was god I was going
to do that one I believe there's been
inquiries for me to do I'm a celebrity
get me out of here yeah in some some of
the other other countries
okay
which I don't want to do that either
it's you know let's you got it you gotta
eat [ __ ] bugs and [ __ ]
I posed and Kalpana PSA's and [ __ ] I
want to do that yeah now you did mention
special so I want make sure we plug your
special special yeah these business
Friday's coming in it's all bit called
this is me now and it's gonna be on
Netflix
or is it this is me now which way it's
exactly this is this is me now is a
punchline to a big story that's in the
routine it's not like and so people are
already getting into me like oh look -
before before he was a Libertad [ __ ]
[ __ ] oh I came back was just told
hookahs it drag yeah and this special
only has like I'm gonna say four minutes
and shop in the whole world it's four
minutes cool and that's it was that on
purpose yeah last special freedom that
was sort of like oh yeah I only had five
minutes of jump name no rest it was all
about the Constitution yeah yeah and all
the freedoms are not that they were that
sure that he was laying there yeah I'm
like that was the bit yeah but like I
thought like that there was a chance
that he was going to be remembered like
mr. t just this bloke that we all they
were that sure that he was like yeah but
like I thought like that there was a
chance that he was going to be
remembered like mr. t just this bloke
that we all remember that guy with a
weird haircut presidential candidate mr.
t always got on entretalk Trump mmm I
never took Trump especially to my son I
really talk about him much at home why
why is that I just talk about it at work
all day yeah oh sorry I not also live by
myself well that's all right you do get
burnout on it though I get you burn out
a little bit but I also I live with me
zone now I me my son we watch The Little
Rascals the other day trumps at
beginning of that film he's all the
Disney won the 1994 yeah
amazing movie yeah we're the car race of
the angel Trump's chubs one of their
dads yes he's at the beginning of home
alone right right he's also in the
beginning with millenia of azulon didn't
know that about a week every film that
me and my son watched just had trumpeted
it was just like we were like a homing
pigeons he's a missing arrow at nine
he's like the dog can't catch yeah yeah
and [ __ ] the first time we watch like
Zoolander was I thought I will get a few
laughs of this yes like I was silly
goofy yeah and so beginning he's like Oh
Derek Zoolander he's such a whatever I
got did he birthday yeah and then like I
soon as soon as chump came up with a
screen my son goes how will this movie
is ruined
right that's timing Lee I go what about
total trap he goes he's the worst person
in the world right dad and I'm like I
guess they're teaching him that in their
little liberal schools we got to I guess
I mean well he's probably surrounded by
the kids of I mean you talked he
probably watches my bloody show [ __ ]
now he's my boy he puts it on a bit yeah
now is it is it weird for you because
you weren't necessarily a political
comedian and then you got the gun bid
and then the show and now do people
expect you to talk about politics yeah I
don't know what I am anymore I don't
know like like I get the reviews I think
my stand-up show he's a fine they like
like I work with the atom and stuff but
my reviews are like now it's like didn't
talk about guns didn't talk about
politics and it's like well it did was
talking about politics and it's like
well I say I try to do like a whole lot
of sex and drug routines and a little
bit of politics to stop it forever
yeah but Colin used to do that County
like these big long bits on fighting and
everyone just remembers him talking
about yeah he's near this and and it is
bad for you Harlan has my favorite fart
joke ever where he says uh how do you
know in a moth farts it's the only time
that it flies straight
that's my favorite part joke ever and it
and it's from the guy that has the seven
dirty words and all the politics and
everything like that well you can do it
all you don't have to be it's like
amazing that the people get super grumpy
if you're not living up to their exact
expectation of what I think you should
be they had they have an idea of what
they came to see about a cookie who in
the home to take you to prep for this
special or when did you go all right
Brock I'm a little puffy and red in this
special eye nobody work out and try to
look a bit leaner on the specials mm-hmm
but it was at the end of a one month to
her across Britain so the chances of me
looking good part of this is veno
I love me look like a [ __ ] slob in
this bedroom
I just is it I mean you walk into any
pub in Britain and you just I mean get
the world yeah it's the thing is like
specially after gigs people think that
that you're gonna get [ __ ] wasted
every night and you do one night I do
well I do one night out of three yeah
yeah that's all you I get [ __ ] that
100th yeah I'm not someone who and you
know you had me on your podcast I wasn't
sober yeah we had we had some but I did
bring the next day like sorry bro yeah
that wasn't interesting wise Don Adam
yeah vine that were that even I mean
Adam is such you know heroes with
everything but there are a couple face I
saw his where he looked at me being like
[Laughter]
that was a phone call yeah I have and
this is real addict come like sentence
an attic sentence to say I have zero
interest in one or two alcoholic
beverages I'm no interested yeah I don't
know what these people are I'm gonna
have for one drink I love a beer after
work I live 10 B's
or nobis yeah so you're all right I'm
all right with no yeah yeah but if I'm
going for it I'm going for it wait for
it yesterday good after on Tuesdays
Tuesdays we get [ __ ] up but we do a
podcast nice and after the show soon as
we get off we all to stop [ __ ]
hammering it every day every Tuesday
Tuesday one also you get cookies on
Tuesdays so hoagies on Tuesday rules
yeah shoes days the best Tuesday
afternoons good Tuesday mornings
horrible morning you go learn things
yeah well cuz that all cuz that's your
taping day yeah yeah yeah yeah I enjoy
that's why I got the to television so I
come in and I watch it a little bit of
something on that screen and then that's
mattelli prompt screen oh it seems I
kind of get familiar my can practice the
teleports awesome your vet I was
watching clips few days ago and you're
really good at it that's it that's
another skill set that I feel like yeah
I wasn't we are now one day they are
going better are is yeah well I used to
have two disorients member you know
what's happened I'm just like shaking
I'm Milwaukee right so I just gave up
reading books years ago yes so so the
books in the officer for show these are
ones that were given to me okay so I was
a guest he sign this guy sent me a book
that's another guy who sent me a Trump
thing that somebody just sent me naked
cookbook that Brad Pitt this is the pie
boy I was if I'm a pirate so this was
actually the Playmate of the Year
Edition okay don't you see there's how
much I enjoyed a Playboy it is 20
questions with Jim Jeffries article it
is amazing so so long as I play Matthew
so there's the Playmate of the Year
alright attractive woman yeah and so I
got to go to the Playmate of the Year
awards like where she was crowned or
whatever hell yeah and so I went along
with it was a it was a lunch just up the
road and I Hotel I was like oh look at
that steak yeah I got [ __ ] up didn't
know but I go I gotta walk and then I
see her and she's signing everyone's
copies that type of stuff and and I did
the old sea
there was going up the magazine yeah so
I walked up to it
I saw a Miss for you my article so I
said appointment he is like over my
picture she was a fun girl there you go
how are Playboy's are they they're still
rockin and rollin is that yeah but every
month they what they did was they did
about a year where they went we're done
with the nudes Yeah right what yeah they
took away because they're like gods free
on the internet
yeah porn everywhere right yeah we're
done with the nudes and then like they
went all right come on bring back the
news that was the one that was the yeah
that was the coke two of Playboy who's
he son runs the met his son runs the
magazine now yep what's his name
Oh Cooper Cooper Cooper Hefner yeah he
[ __ ] looks like he's dead man yeah a
lot he's also like 27 and getting
married like a regular chick like you
see yeah where are you you buddies with
with Pete Davidson yeah yeah yeah he's
great yeah there's like it's like a
three fold and you're like it's Ariana
Grande
yeah I can do it you can son yeah and it
was like this everyone's like that ring
is over $100,000 why did he spend that
much and I'm like he divorces out for
years
that's a hill rock out a quick five
million in the end what you know one for
the men yeah it's funny I was having
that exact conversation with somebody
where like if if they split up he's
gonna get a bunch of money and then the
person was like well no cuz it's her
money and she should keep it and he
didn't earn that money I'm like uh-huh
that's how yeah so that that's it I did
a logical I didn't have it's like we did
a joke a couple of weeks ago that whole
thing about the World Cup but they going
with Burger King the Burger King on a
promotion
in the wind in Russia oh nice okay right
where if you're getting pregnant by one
of the World Cup footballs you get free
hamburgers for life I mean you gotta eat
man that McDonald's Burger King rivalry
is sure yeah yeah but they guys and I
got pretty Perkins for yeah yeah get
impregnated by me you get a house yeah
yeah I imagine like if you get him
pregnant by Russian footballer then
that's what you got like you know you
have au cup fire any World Cup play Wow
alright alright gold diggers start your
engines yeah exactly I was on that it's
when you say on the show
oh god this is sad there's is there
anything we can even joke about [ __ ] it
let's give it a go yeah do you is there
stuff that you ever see or come across
that you feel like you just like we
can't make a joke there or yeah I think
that was the trickiest one was the kids
being the atom like separated from their
rap for their family although I am doing
a stand-up routine about that make up a
few people that I feel like just well
the kids of eggs over family so 23andme
came in to give him all like DNA tests
so they can match the families back up
right that's gotta be like the worst
Maury Povich episode ever there's gotta
be at least one incidence where yeah
you're not the father
yeah it's like I carried who on my back
3-1 now
like do you do you try do you sit down
and go I'm gonna write something about
this topic because it is controversial
or a TV show for fervor easier acting
yeah stand-ups a different thing saying
Stan I don't know you guys do put on
armor I'm a big you know just wait for
it to come to you yeah
you just sit around and then go oh yeah
that might be a bit bit really special
is coming out so I'm in panic mode right
now yeah look sure if I have enough yeah
the worst time to see me do stand-up
comedy is July 14th
one day after his special this is me now
debuts on that plate it'll be slightly
better on the 15th yeah much do you make
it will you perform on yeah y'all good
gigs I got a five doesn't see the Raider
on the [ __ ] 17th up and I'm like how
much so do you really throw out the hole
yeah I do anyway I always I have like I
think I'd like forty minutes in you and
then I at the moment and then I have
like then I start there's like a whole
lot of routines that I never recorded
that I sort of salvage and bring back to
sort of Pat it out a little bit yeah and
then last somebody of your level like
how much material do you have shelf that
you're just that for whatever reason you
you left off off the money yeah yeah now
and stuff but a lot of it was edited net
because it wasn't that great
well then I'm yeah but then when you're
done you're just trying to create a new
hour these people oh yeah you got to do
something and then and there sometimes I
I'll tell you a funny story that
happened to me because we we actually in
the last episode we had this thing
called apartment in a good for another
15-20 yeah yeah I'm just I got some
sushi or Robbie understand along the
life for Jim Jefferies I am she's cookie
Tuesday's sushi Wednesday's this is
graham sushi and cookies can be the name
of your next question you know Ireland
and we did this this thing called
apartment because you know Alan what's
happening is they're changing the
marketing laws so you can't you can
advertise alcohol you can't have a
person in the advert and you can't have
like a beach you can't make it look nice
you get like smoking over there now you
can just have the alcohol and against be
the advert can be big four pounds twenty
well that's all you really need but no I
copy a hot chick and it can't be a beach
like it's you know I mean I mean we have
some absurd advertising rules here for
alcohol where no one can drink the
alcohol in the ad so like you can have
Neil Patrick Harris holding a Heineken
and he could be about to sip it but you
can't actually see him drink which is
ruined
yeah that's a weird thing yeah so
whatever was there I just drank with
some alcoholics and islands right and
these guys do about 15 points a day
chase and anyway say so in an hour and a
half mm-hm
we had in the interview in the hour and
a half we all went through six
guinnesses and six shots of Jameson
right to speed things oh wow
at the end I was led that's an
hour-and-a-half yeah
dribbling yeah right and they're like
are you really drunk you can't handle
your liquor and I'm like it's like it's
trying to act tough for me yeah good
[ __ ] good all right
so I leave but I'm at that stage of
drunk where I was just like I let's keep
rocking this out mm-hmm so bond because
we had the bar as I said this power saw
all it was 50 years all in America just
to put it in context whoa so Adam that
would make it opened in years older than
what America seventeen seventeen fifty
67 right yeah yeah fifty years would be
30 20 26 26 yes what was the question
17:26 that's when the bar opened yeah
okay sorry I just made everyone do math
so I'm gonna hide the bar and just find
them rings it's fine it was fine rings
hmm and I pick up the phone and I'm
drunk like I'm pouring again as ladies
pour my own be behind the body yeah and
I had hey Jay Leno I've never met Jay
Leno in my entire life and I'm legless
ly drunk yeah and Jay doesn't drink yeah
I'm like hey um I'm gonna be doing a
stand-up spot on The Tonight Show like
that right all right our congratulations
on getting this in our show
who books that but yes because I ever
retained and someone's told me in
similar to one of your routines I want
to run it by you
he's nice thing to do yeah turns out for
mine it was pretty much the same joke no
the joke was they used to do about how
like male strippers are always like
firemen or yeah police officer or
whatever right I go because they even
when a man's naked a woman wants to know
that he has a job
okay hey Joe so so why so I got look
he's a deal I recorded that giant made
me five years ago I said if you want to
do it I don't give a [ __ ] but if anyone
asks I'll say that you rang up and you
asked if you could do it you know and
he's great thanks James thanks it's
really sweaty yeah my man so anyways
there we keep we keep we keep drinking
and the two young comics come up and
they were like hey you know we were new
comics but we were photo and I'm like
sure and I go what are you guys doing
here and I was like oh we ran a comedy
gig in the basement and they didn't ask
me closely drunk I was like all open for
yeah don't worry I'm so drunk guy so I
go downstairs okay there's maybe 15 yeah
people in there and so and then the next
day I'm doing a 4,000 seat room in
Dublin right cuz I mean but the day
before I'm in this 15 seat venue is like
an old pub it's they go oh we have very
special guests like their old college
type age please welcome Jim Jefferies
not one of those 50 when you hear the
[ __ ] one but one and so I was like I
was like well what I'll do is I'll just
do a routine mm-hmm that just one story
and they'll [ __ ] off
right so I decided to tell that the the
I I performed for a party for Mariah
Carey yeah
and Al Pacino was there I you know yeah
so so I was like I was like so I'll just
tell that's three now what I had
forgotten is because I don't do a lot of
little clubs and stuff a lot of my
material now is by
around the fact of you knowing who I am
and previous previous routine that I've
done I'm dropping I'm just like anyway
so Eddie Murphy was there and then Al
Pacino's over there and then they
requested the gun control room it was
literally me telling people I'm famous
you don't know who I am but I'm famous
yeah so I'm doing all the different
different impersonations and stuff it's
dying and the story there's no easy way
to get out of story I'm locked in yeah
the whole thing I'm like oh I got out of
15 minutes of this [ __ ] story I got
it all while completely hammered yeah Oh
what completely smashed out of my face
yeah the gigs going terribly it was in
the back like before rings yeah Jay Leno
no this is Savage see so I turn on
speakerphone hold on you guys hey lad
I'm not gonna do that junk then they'll
appoint me doing that joke I got I got
all the material I can do a different
joke anyway thanks for being so cool
about it and I'm like all right you know
I go that was I Jay Leno and this girl
in the audience like dropped so many
names yeah she went sure it was they all
thought that the geek McClendon I gotta
cover yeah eight to the back and I go if
the gig goes band ring up and do the Jay
Leno do the thing that always saves my
show yeah and that's just and that's
just 15 people going this guy's really
committing to the whole I'm famous bit
yeah Jay Leno is calling me remember
what's that Beyonce Jay's car show twice
and then one time I was like on holiday
and I decide to extend my holiday by
waking so I said I cancel and then
another time I cancel because I was
you know I had a wasn't heal I had like
a surgery or something that I knew I
wasn't going to be able to know and I
know I haven't been invited back since I
think I cancelled on Jay too many times
the race cars I still haven't gotten
coffee with that other guy either yeah
yeah like a monster yeah there's a new
season that you should do it I feel like
I don't know how you get like I hear
that it's no yeah those guys he hasn't
met it seems like a fun gig and that
you're always curious kind of the same
way how your writers write jokes for you
go what car would he pick like what car
would he pick for you that's like and
this and this call his old rugged run
down there's a lot of cocaine in it
which brings me to my guess it's a dirty
car hasn't been washed in years
I wonder where you find some Australian
vehicle yes surely what's the best
Australian car I'd like to think that
he'd get me like the Monaro format from
Mad Max Wow yeah yeah it does doesn't
stray Leah have a car company we just
lost that last one but we did for it we
did for many many many many years we had
Ford was Australian we had our own
branch of Ford which I made Ford's just
for Australia and Holden was the company
and Holden made all the videos we did
muscle cars the same as you guys did
muscle cars
okay so yes so that's why Mad Max always
had the big were all the last of the
[ __ ] V ice right there are aliens and
the original Mad Max there you go only
you are you gonna go back there soon
right there in January
uncle I'm doing I'm done I'm going to do
a small tour of Australia I think
tickets gone silent edye next I'm gonna
do five gigs and the only reason I'm
doing the to Australia's because my
brothers getting married I'll just slap
it on and try and then you pay then you
pay for the trip and yeah money and pay
for your brother's gift yes I have to I
have to go to if you have spots you'll
hit when you go back that you just
always or a must like food yeah oh yeah
yeah
chocolates a few are places in
there's a fast-food place I like called
old gal a burger which has a nice
chicken it's Portuguese chicken thing or
Gala or galas BJ a lot more golly a
little bit of food in this strange
dynamite really good time you bait yeah
yeah I just went he just went I'm going
through overly I'm going for the first
time in December cities oh oh that's
right I'm competing with you in H city
you son of a [ __ ] you got me the gig to
tell you about that why don't I just
open up for you make it easier yeah
that's like the Washington Generals and
yeah yeah I did bread's universe I'm
towns that you are yeah yeah your your
your opening act Forrest told me about
it and I'm like great why don't I just I
think I think we double up on two cities
maybe okay so those so those will be the
cities where plenty tickets will be will
be available for my Australian show tell
you what I'll do I'll plug in the cities
that you're going in next take time
there we go I'll do it on the show and
then sell those ones that for you thank
you very much and thank you thank you
for getting me those gigs oh that's okay
we were in Perth on Australia Day yeah
it's pretty awesome yeah it's a good
City yeah it was um there's a big
firework show on the Swan River yeah
[Laughter]
everything all right yeah because I
started in comedy in Perth and so I
wikipedia says that I'm from Perth what
I'm learning from Sydney mm-hmm but when
they decorated my office there was going
to be surprise for season two when I
came back in and they didn't do much
research the decorator just looked at
Wikipedia so there's a lot of maps of
Perth yeah well now they they also
decorated with quite a few Superman
comics are you in the Superman
well that that's something you can talk
about with Seinfeld when you finally do
your committees and cars no actually I
like him I feel like other superheroes
are redundant
mm-hmm no once you've got the Justice
League why'd you get Superman the rest
of them are useless yeah yeah Aquaman's
only rock around the water Batman can't
physically do anything like it Batman
once again like like Batman vs Superman
is just like yeah yeah the man would
crush him now I know it didn't turn out
that way how did it turn out it isn't
Batman wore a [ __ ] kryptonite suit
yeah because he's smart I think that
should be the name of your next special
like you in the movie what happened with
that fight I wore a kryptonite that's on
the cutsy wait you said you started in
Sydney where we're at birth birth yeah
it was a comedy club a comedy club there
was no comedy club in Perth the time
there was a Wednesday night above a pub
called the brass monkey nice wow that
was really wait you sign up you just
what was it open microwave every mic
yeah and then I I just I did what a lot
of my kids do I promote it okay what
happen was talked about how you knew
jaylen there was it there was a serial
killer in this very fancy suburb that
used to have all these nightclubs and
stuff
mmm called in Clermont called the claim
what killer I just found him a oh oh
[ __ ] wow they just faint but he killed a
whole heap of girls and they thought for
a while was taxi drivers and so I
thought was he's one bloke and they kept
following him around in a police car
forever gang this is the black they put
him on the news that killed himself and
now this bit whips in found out it
wasn't here so whoops sorry [ __ ] yeah
you so the Clairemont killer so this
used to be like a hub of like or like
like nightlife for all the students
yeah I mean then but the last thing that
all the girls were killed they went off
to get a taxi and that's when they got
killed
okay and so that all of a sudden that
area why this is the height of the
killings were other college
that area was dead so this is like all
these really like really nice rooms you
could do for comedy and I was like good
I come to a comedy show here because
girls didn't want to come he's probably
shape my whole career because girls
wouldn't come into town yeah it was just
like I do these gigs just like [ __ ]
50 bikes getting killed
oh hey now people know where you let
misogynistic comedy but just because the
Klan one killer was I need people to go
see your Netflix special this is me now
as especially as I can learn what
docking is I need people to go see your
Netflix special this is me now as
especially as I can learn what docking
is darkening it's work that's just that
alone letting is the docking routine
yeah I do it's like is where you wrap a
foreskin around the head of non foreskin
penis and they link together and there's
a bit of suction soon as you see it you
understand it always makes you think
what will the guys think of so so the
eye I know we do that routine here in
America and then the whole I do a whole
lot of think about how uncircumcised
dicks a gross right and then the
audience of each ear here is on my side
cuz Americans for the most part I'd say
and then I find like a guy in the
audience who isn't circumcised then we
make the audience really pick on him and
I asked you know I say say how do you
live with yourself you're disgusting
yeah so it's over the top right mmm but
then I recorded this special in London
where no one circumcised I'll just give
the routine ago anyway so instead of
like ever cheering is everyone booing me
dicks our oldest you got a weird digs
this so it hasn't even the special
hasn't even come out and I'm expecting a
lot of height mouth after that because
I'm circumcision is mutilation blah blah
blah blah but I'm getting intact avast's
they called what's that and the people
who don't want you what a band
circumcision and the Eagles activists
activists they wanna keep it in science
there's a word for everything it's the
int activists are showing up at my case
the dictators yeah and they're like
circumcision ruins sexual pleasure
circumcision this circumcisions
mutilation like this right the funding
is mark fans like they're all like
taking photos in front of the place I
just love the fact that the the people
that come to protest you are pro gun and
anti-circumcision yes that's your Jim
Jefferies hate groups right there yeah
yeah I'm fine with the show it's like
it's like the it matter people send me
hate mail after the show and it's like
how are you angry at that it's like it's
like me saying in the show I think the
kids should be reunited with the parents
yeah liberals like okay I didn't say
that they should be let into the country
in order to stop I believe illegal is in
the title illegal immigrant but I do not
believe they should be separated from
the parents their children
that's an extra thing right right and
then like the people who are so angry at
me like like you don't [ __ ] welcome to
this [ __ ] country there any like what
that was losing jumpers yeah yeah I feel
like people I think everyone
fundamentally thinks they're a good
person right like you must agree yeah
you live with your personal be self all
day
sure some good quality yeah I give I
give
waitresses really a large tips every now
and then to get laid
like like yeah like I remember my
youngest there was a girl who used to
just brag to her friends the brat like
I'm talking my early twenties used to
brag to her friends like he is just the
sweetest most honest and it's more
integrity than any man I met in my
entire life and I was cheating on a
constant [ __ ] here I say these things
are dire be like Oh God
[Laughter]
the Netflix special this is me now by
the time this airs uh it'll it'll be
available so go watch it and then 13th
yep
is it everywhere July 3rd think of July
13th is why 14th in Australia oh wow
that's interesting and then we get it we
get it at midnight New York oh I say we
get it midnight
LA yeah does it sweep according to a
geographic location earlier for
circumcised people like we're putting it
on 11:00 a.m. like he's there like it's
a great question yeah so I guess people
would ask me are what is it midnight
Thursday I think it isn't midnight
Friday
well hey guys it's midnight Thursday oh
yeah so Friday so it's coming out either
way go to bed when you wake up it's
there you'll be able to watch so what
watch this is me now watch this is a
streaming company yeah ah streaming you
want to see Netflix Netflix tell me that
that I wouldn't like my specials when
you look through its my specials and not
remain recommended well could you watch
it too much RuPaul's Drag Race I'm
watching oh I watch these RuPaul's Drag
Race and Pixar films we're gonna find
your oh yeah
Jim Gerry not for you well so unless
your name is Jim Jefferies go watch the
Jim Jefferies specials and you will
enjoy it otherwise it's a show and yeah
I guess after the show right every with
the podcast let's go to Jim Jefferies
show podcast the Jim Jefferies show
enjoin doing the show it's it's a it's a
different grind and I kind of like it's
sort of different like I think I enjoyed
slightly more doing a sitcom yeah I
think because sitcoms all about fun and
there's a lot of camaraderie ball
information like acting is like one of
those things where it's like well like
wait I like being an actor because I
feel like a fraud the whole time are you
walking around with all these cameras as
you go on I don't know what I'm doing
yeah yeah I mean where this I sort of
it's closer to stand up so I sort of I
don't feel as out of my comfort zone
here as I did with that real quick how
did you get Brad Pitt Brad Pitt as your
weatherman I had you know with me one
time he's if he's favorite sitcoms legit
shut up it was [ __ ] that means Brad
Pitt has watched someone do cocaine off
my back and just by coincidence
in the audience was Dan back around 8:00
I calls it by the other two characters
yes they just came on to watch an
episode yeah and then before in
rehearsal they were there and I said I
said hey Brad I would say gossip legit
and Brad Pitt lost his [ __ ] it was like
[ __ ] man gray like walked up to him like
he was excited so [ __ ] cool yeah yeah
yeah so he just hit you up and why like
let's get dinner and right there was the
I Netflix what happened was he was doing
a movie called war machine for Netflix
yeah and then it was like like I've been
told that he was a fan of mine and they
wanted to meet up and then they said hey
you can who do you want to have
interview you for the extra features for
war machine and you guys I have Jim
Jefferies but I've never interviewed
anybody I don't think it ever gotten to
the
maybe the worst interview initially I
was like nervous just you walking going
so your bread questions I thought might
be interesting so yeah how much is a
gallon of milk was the last time you in
a grocery store yeah already Wikipedia
you play basketball as a kid oh yeah
what do you ask Brad Pitt he's been in
every single I've gotten better at the
interviewing yeah absolutely yeah you
shocked you even talked to Jack can you
run out and get me food I'm staring out
there getting angry at me there is a
show waiting to be made called Brad and
Brad where Brad Williams travel the
world for a year I mean or at least a
week he's maybe running noises guys he's
looking what happened was he was meant
to be our weather man once mm-hmm and
then he went like just so he filmed the
one thing on the pilot it was like a
favor to help me out the safe yeah right
and then unlike and then it's like I
guess he enjoyed it and so then he'd
start text messaging me really late at
night he was filming and like Mumbai or
something and he just text messaged me
like any pour water over his head it was
just on an iPhone it was like hey Jim
I'm here Mumbai the water levels are
rising oh my god it's any funny videos
yeah he was writing his own bits there's
another one where he's in Venice and
he's in a gondolier he goes as you can
see the roads are completely gone and
like so that's the only clip we could
get because because he was sitting
outside in the gondola so he could only
get like 10 second be honest because at
the end was ended up because at the end
of each clip there's just but loads of
people just losing their [ __ ] shirt with
a big old seventies time
some people just going wow Brad's making
some interesting fashion choices
nowadays I think it was Disraeli filmed
like there's a bit where I go he fired
him and we made this into look like a
70s 70s house right we had the fire the
weatherman he's sitting that is drinking
of whiskey he goes why I love that
well I love saying this your sushi has
arrived so like you we're gonna wrap
this up but once again with what Rezac
party yeah big sushi it's really old
ones yeah watch watch the special watch
the show on Comedy Central subscribe to
the podcast and go see go see me on tour
instead of him in Australia